So, wir sitzen auf dem Congress, das ist der 39C3, ihr hört die Geräuschkulisse um uns herum.
Es tut mir so leid.
Die Kassette, die wo zehn Tage drauf passen, ein bisschen technisch lustig gelöst.
Also man ist gerade so über die Halbzeit, man spürt so ein bisschen schon im Hinterkopf die Melancholie, dass es morgen vorbei sein wird.
Der nette Mensch, der diese Veranstaltung da, diesen App Beginner Workshop, geleitet hat, kommt aus Southern California, aus LA, glaube ich, meinte er.
Dass viele Leute da auch IoT-Sachen drüber mitmachen.
Auf dem Congress eher seid ihr rumlaufer und rumgucker und gehe in die Talks.
Auf die Art und Weise, kannst du Peer-to-Peer-Anwendungen bauen.
Hast du auch einen Workshop mitgemacht?
Und der hat bestimmte Ankerpunkte in den Besierkurven, heißt das glaube ich.
Nee, das vierte, dritte?
So, und jetzt muss ich dann noch selber wirklich.
Aber vor Ort hat es dann doch irgendwie geklappt.
Es hat sich schon die ganze Zeit angefühlt wie Tag eins.
Das war ja am laufenden Band.
Von Anna Biseli.
Das ist ja gerade das Schöne, dass es hier so ultra divers ist und so unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten.
Und die sind dann meistens an Tag 1 um 1 Uhr nachts in Saal 1.
Nee, wir hatten.
Vor allem halt auch scary, weil ich Angst hatte, dass also es ist ja ein interaktives Projekt gewesen, sprich das Publikum nimmt teil.
Das heißt, da sind sehr viele Gedanken da reingeflossen, wie ich das so ein bisschen quasi absichere, was nicht bedeutet, dass ich das sehr gut gemacht habe.
Es war richtig, richtig geil.
Es war nicht schlimm und ihr habt auf jeden Fall gut.
die das Publikum quasi auch noch so Fragen beantworten kann mit so lustigen Fragen.
Achso, ich muss kurz abgewählt, wenn Tim Pritlough plötzlich hinter einem steht und so kurz hinschaut, was wir hier machen.
Ich hätte kurz am Tag 1 und am Tag 0 mit dem Network Operations gequatscht, ob die mir irgendwo Vorschläge haben.
Wir hatten Ben mit auf der Bühne.
Wir haben ihn gestern dabei gehabt, dass er nicht nur Pausmelodie spielt, sondern auch quasi die ganzen Überbrückungen im Spiel mitgespielt hat, aber auch diverse
andere Melodien, also die aus diversen Computerspielen auch mit.
Dass der Tonabnehmer von Ben überhaupt nicht funktioniert hatte.
Witzigerweise waren aber nur Websockets kaputt.
Aber ich hatte ja eine Netzwerkverbindung.
Und dann habe ich aber den Zeiten Browser aufgemacht, habe noch ein Chromium aufgemacht und schaut, ob es da geht.
Und nicht aus dem Beamer-View, sondern aus dem Host-View, weil wenn ich auf dem Beamer-View, wie ich es ursprünglich gemacht hatte, das abspiele, da habe ich keine
Interaction gehabt, weil ich da nicht mit dem Maustacker drauf geklickt habe und da hat der Browser sich teilweise geweigert, das TTS abzuspielen.
Und dass anscheinend das Publikum auch eine gute Zeit hatte.
Und wir haben so ein bisschen generell mit denen so geredet über, was bedeutet das, was bedeutet das für die Zukunft, was für Möglichkeiten hat man als Lehrer und
Lehrerin vielleicht damit umzugehen, dass die
Und da hatten wir eben die Idee, dieses Konzept, dieses Spiel, mit dem mal zu spielen, zwischendrin einfach nur so ein bisschen das Ganze aufzulockern.
Ich dachte, hier ist meine E-Mail-Adresse, ihr schickt mir einfach die Antworten auf die Prompts und ich packe die als Texteditor auf den Beamer einfach so kleine
Fenster nebeneinander und dann stimmen wir mit Melden ab, was die KI war.
Das werde ich vorher rausführen.
Oh, das ist.
Und habe alle Leute angesprochen und ich glaube der zehnte oder elfte oder so, den ich angesprochen habe, ja, das war der.
Und die kann ich in meinem Handy stecken und dann auch über das interne GSM-Netz, aber nichts ist so stabil wie DECT.
Vielleicht erhalten wir auch dann erst ab dem 42C3 Veranstaltungen, äh, Postkarten aus der Zukunft.
Dann wisst ihr, was die Datenspuren sind.
Und das wollte ich noch mal kurz einbringen als ein bisschen Follow-up.
dass die Bandbreite hier ziemlich gefüllt ist und hunderte andere Sachen hier rumfunken.
Irgendwie dazu geäußert, wofür man das praktisch zum Einsatz bringen kann?
Da habe ich auch eine ganz lustige, äh, eine lustige Projektidee hinter Kopf, aber da will ich vorher nochmal ein bisschen rumgoogeln, ob man damit, ob das überhaupt
feasible ist, bevor ich jetzt hier an
Vortrag bisher bezeichnen würde.
Der Aufnahme ist ein bisschen aus dem Känguru vorgelesen, dass im Neuen.
Und das so voranschieben, einfach, dass wir das IFG bekommen haben, dass Menschen dahinter stehen, das auch dementsprechend nutzen können und quasi ein Gegenpol
existiert zu so absolut
Genauso wie bei Frag den Stat so dieser Jahres.
Besuchen, zwei Workshops machen und ein fantastische Zeit haben.
dem Kurs.
können.
Das sind einfach nur einfach saufile Schichten dafür.
Könnten ja einfach dem CCA gegenüber mit erfüllen.
so ein bisschen Geschichte, auch die Geschichte, die die Songtexte selber hat mich sehr nachdenklich gemacht.
Die großen Vortragsehle, aber das ist ja gefühlt nur so 2% von dem, was hier stattfindet.
die ich auch sehr schön fand und zwar war das GPT-Dash.
Essentiell auch für dieses Problem.
Hm, übrigens, wir haben im Yolo Colo Leute, die haben 100 Gigabit-Ablenk.
Deswegen mussten wir die spontan nur wieder reinkopieren.
Eine Bratsche brennt länger als ein Geige.
Von zwei Stimmen parallel vorgelesen wurde und die andere war eine viel modernere, neue, generate Stimme.
die Schüler und Schülerinnen alle sowas mit nutzen.
Wir hatten früher die Seidenstraße, wir haben mittlerweile auch, also mittlerweile ist es Quatsch, wir haben seit vielen Jahren auch die Chaos-Post, wo man intern
Posts zustellen kann.
Und die Postkarte war nicht mal von hier.
SIP-Client auf dem Handy dann.
ist und dann sagst du auf die zweite Nachkommastelle genau, wie viel Mate du noch hast in deiner Mate.
Habt ihr früher auch manchmal Postkarten gesammelt, die es so in Kneipen gab und dann einfach in der Wiki an die Wand gehängt?
Zwei Arduino Nano oder es könnte auch ein Raspberry Pi Nano?
gesagt, weil eigentlich ist ja VGO der Zweig und zumindest hat er mich davon überzeugt, dass man da mal noch mal ein bisschen genauer hingucken muss, wenn man darüber
urteilen will.
Aber ich glaube, in dem Sinne können wir hier einen sauberen Cut machen.
Akronymisierbar, aber definitiv weitere Podcast-Folge in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in 3, 2, 1.
Zu zweit?
Und das ist irgendwo stand so ein Programm, das schaue ich mir noch an, bevor unsere Aufzeichnung ist.
Punkt Reginis-ratzalom.
des Kongresses.
Man mich jetzt inzwischen?
Es gab diverse Workshops, auch so zum selber löten von Dingen, aber ganz am ersten Tag, ganz für so absolute Noobs wie mich, noch einen Beginner-Workshop.
und dann quasi chatten mit anderen Leuten, die auch dieses Netzwerk aufbauen.
Und mehr stastik ist dieses Protokoll, was noch oben drüber gesprochen wird.
Genau, genau.
Und Iroh ist dieses Peer-to-Peer, eigentlich ist das hier gerade Hand in Glove, was wir themenmäßig machen.
Wäre jetzt das, wo es hingehen soll.
Im Bildschirm vor uns kurz.
Wenn man jetzt ein klassisches Grafikprogramm benutzt mit Schrift, das man dann einstellen kann, das soll jetzt regular oder das soll
Diese Schrift soll bold oder regular oder thin sein?
Also tatsächlich am besten gefallen talkmäßig.
wo man jedes Jahr immer wieder hingeht und sich freut, ah, wird es von dem wieder was geben, wird es von dem wieder was geben.
Herrlich.
Statuieren, dass wir das weiterführen können und dass wir heute doch genau dieselben Prinzipien verfolgen wie auch damals, nämlich dass wir die Geschichte sich
nicht wiederholen lassen dürfen.
direkt schon miterleben, was alles schon passiert ist.
Guter Start.
Und sehe das hier als eine große Vorlesereihe.
Und am Späti verenden und das ist zum Beispiel was, was ich idealerweise so an einer Bar Sachen verkaufen, das kann ich.
Eigentlich auch nur eine Bar, aber hat dann halt tatsächlich noch so diese kleinen, diese kleinen Zusatzsachen.
16 Kästen Bier dann auf der Ameise da hochfährt und sich durch die Menschenmassen durchbrüllen muss.
Großartig der Rest ist und wie viele kleine Sachen halt überall stattfinden, wie viele unglaublich viele self organized sessions gibt.
Genau, alles, was nicht aufgezeichnet wird, abwohl ich das auf jeden Fall und dann Filter auf nicht aufgezeichnet machen und dann das abarbeiten.
Spätabends hier ankommen.
Die Late-Night Slots, die Primetime Slots.
sondern all die Leute, die potenziell das Know-how haben und auch manchmal ein bisschen Spaß daran haben, so ein bisschen rumzuforschen, wie was läuft, auch mit mir
selber im Raum sitzen, während wir das alle benutzen.
Also, wir haben das gestern Abend gespielt, ich bin auch immer noch ein bisschen fertig davon.
Also wir haben die, kurz zur Erklärung, die ganzen Prompts, die wir vorbereitet haben.
Du hast einen interaktiven Teil, jeder, jeder Besucher, jede Besucherin im Publikum hat mit
gespielt.
Spiel zu machen und auf der Bühne irgendwie fragen und dann Preise zu organisieren.
wie ich habe nach jeder Runde so einen Zurücksetzen-Button gehabt, um die SpielerInnen rauszuwerfen und die Publikumscores zu besetzen.
Aber das ist auch super schwer zu erkennen, wer denn die Hände oben hatte von draußen.
Ist während irgendwie die Leute auf der Bühne die Teilnehmer irgendwie Prompts schreiben sollten und das Publikum Trivia-Fragen beantworten sollte, hattet ihr
auch noch Live-Musik auf der Bühne?
Die wir dann auch das Publikum hatten erraten lassen wollen.
Wie viele Spiele gibt es in der Zelda-Serie?
Klops an Benni, der eine ganz fantastische Struktur für dieses Spiel sich überlegt hat.
Gefunkt haben, aber wir hatten wirklich ein richtig geiles Konzept, wie wir das halt auch so nach und nach so das Spiel immer weiter so ein bisschen ausbauen und
verbessern und noch mehr, die Leute mehr übernehmen lassen.
Perfekte Chaos Communication Compass Veranstaltung.
Ja, aber ihr habt ja seitdem alles nochmal neu gemacht.
Also theoretisch, wie gesagt, kommt das Spiel nicht mal von den Datenspuren.
Die wollten so ein bisschen, die haben uns eingeladen, uns beide, wir bauen damals Benni macht immer noch Carsmachtschule sehr, sehr viel mit.
Und da hatten wir leider gar keine Software für.
Abgefahren.
Sabrina.
Auf demselben Event.
Ganz fantastisch.
Mal bitte mit der Chaos-Post direkt jetzt hier an dem Podcast-Tisch eine Postkarte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das steht im Programmpunkt übrigens.
an dem Kippenautomaten vorbeigegangen.
Aber das ist auch noch so ein Take-Away für mich.
Es gibt nicht ganz die Badge, aber was ich so entdeckt hatte, waren noch diese RFID Ingress-like Scan-Dinger, die du hast.
und gewartet, dass du die Farbe von dem Ding geändert hast.
und dann hinterher direkt über die Fahrplan-App die Videos angucken.
Es ist insane.
nicht auf Fotos ist und so weiter.
und in dieses Mesh-Network irgendwie bereitstellen und dann kannst du dich entweder direkt von deiner Note oder mit einem anderen Gerät mit deiner Note verbinden.
die es dir erlauben, auch so Peer-to-Peer-Applikationen zu bauen.
DHT von BitTorrent.
verteilten Geräten aufzubauen.
Ja, ähm, hätte ich gestern anziehen müssen bei dem Vortrag, ähm, aber.
Kannst du mit Inkscape bauen, ne?
Machst du, indem du dann irgendein Programm benutzt, was das als eine Schrift exportiert.
Und jetzt kommt es aber irgendwie so langsam in den Mainstream, dass du eben Schriften entwickeln kannst, die so definiert sind, dass sich diese Ankerpunkte bewegen
können nach einem definierten Weg.
einer weiteren Person diese Schrift für den man 30C3 mitentwickelt hat.
simplen Zeichen wirklich gut.
Sagen wir beratungsresistenten PolitikerInnen wie naja, okay, den Namen brauche ich jetzt nicht nennen.
Wir sollten dem Beispiel uns annehmen und das nicht eine einmalige Gelegenheit in der Geschichte passieren lassen, sondern genau das wieder tun und mit der AfD das
Exempel zu
Relativ fast genau, na wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr besucht, aber tatsächlich zwei Workshops.
unglaublich viele Türen gibt, die und die Evakier, wir haben ja dieses glaube ich neu dabei.
die die ganzen Bars mit zu versorgen.
Wiederwabert.
und zu einer Geburtstagsparty-Einladung absagen, die am 26.
vier Tage Festival, da will ich nicht schon am Abend davor irgendwie mich ausnocken.
Und dann haben wir gedacht, das ist doch ein lustiges Spiel.
Mit einem Telefon.
Okay, das klingt schon ein bisschen beängstigender, aber klar passt auch und dann haben wir es alleins bekommen.
Und ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, mal eine Anwendung gebaut zu haben, wo nicht nur ein technikbasiertes Publikum existiert.
So funktioniert hat, wie wir es wollten.
Zeit hatten, ihren Prompt zu schreiben.
geantwortet und dann das Publikum musste abstimmen, was war jetzt KI und was war jetzt am lustigsten.
Sachen eingereicht haben, haben irgendwie auf ihrem Endgerät irgendwie ein Zeichen gekriegt und durften sie auch noch einen Preis abholen.
Sehr frickelig im Spielen und manche Sachen liefen dann auch nicht so schön im Ablauf, wie ich dann im Fanach festgestellt hatte.
Und ich habe von, also das hat Ben selber die Antwortmöglichkeiten vorgegeben, der nicht mehr spielen können, die Tyvia-Frage dazu.
Holz arbeitet.
konsequent zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die KI-Stimme abgerissen ist, dann einfach selber weiter vorgelesen.
Der Bühne von Saal 1, wo die Live-Demo so ein bisschen gehakt hat, weil der Presenter-Netzwerkprobleme hat.
Den habe ich dann kurzzeitig aufgemacht, aber auch da konnte ich die Seite laden, aber keine Websocket-Verbindung aufbauen.
Quasi ein magisches Kontingent an WebSockets existiert, was ja totaler Quatsch ist, weil die laufen ja auch über Port 443.
spielen und dann habe ich zwei hostpanels offen gehabt und beide haben dann dieses audio abgespielt und chromium hat eine sehr viel bessere tts engine als mein
firefox mit drin deswegen klang ist im moderner
Das gleichzeitig, was Teil der Faszination von so einem Spiel ausmacht und des Unterhaltungsfaktors ist, zu sehen, was ihr da gemacht habt.
Also das wäre cool gewesen.
An der Bar, haben so ein bisschen Revue passieren lassen, sind beide mit einem, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so geilem Gefühl nach Hause gegangen.
Abstimmungsfragen oder Ratefragen oder diese multimodalen Sachen, ja.
Gefahren davon, also war tatsächlich ein sehr cooler Vortrag, leider sehr nicht gut besucht, dafür konnten wir nicht viel, aber das ist ja auch okay, das ist ja auch
voll in Ordnung.
Ja, ja, genau.
Abgefahren.
Auch eine Sache.
Und dann kannst du dein Telefon an deine Matheflasche halten und in die Flasche pusten.
Genau, wunderschön.
Um zu der absoluten Überladung noch hinzuzufügen, man kann auf dem Congress Achievements sammeln, Badges für bestimmte Sachen, die man machen kann.
Das ist für mich Hausaufgabe für nach dem Kongress.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht alles, was wirklich stattgefunden hat.
Dass jetzt Gitti so dieser böse kommerzielle Zweig ist und Zweig habe ich jetzt ja falsch rumgeschrieben.
Aber vielleicht sind wir ja auch mega schnell und ihr hört sowieso nur unseren Podcast.
Und lustigerweise habe ich dieses Mal beim Kongress eine Person getroffen, die ehemaliger Core-Maintainer von Gitti war.
Kai, schön, dass du dabei bist.
und kann mich mit der verbinden und die ist Teil von diesem Mesh-Network.
Und damit published Infrastruktur laufen, du kannst auch deine eigene aufsetzen.
Und da siehst du zum Beispiel, dass die.
Leute behaupten, ich wäre sowas wie ein Schriftmord.
Ultra thin oder bold oder so sein, nicht wahr?
und mit einem Minimum, einem Maximum und das beinhaltet alles diese Schriftart.
Ja, das ist ja das quasi alles mit wenigen Ausnahmen findet man ja eh in der Konservatanne.
und der etlichen, ich weiß gar nicht wie viele das waren, Polizeifestsetzungen und Inspektionen, die dieser Busan schon über sich ergehen lassen.
Ich habe nämlich zwei Workshops besucht.
Der Workshop ist, wie stecken wir den Arduino und die Lichterkette zusammen und wie kommt das kleine Blinkenleit-Skript auf den Arduino und ich habe leider keinen
Löten gelernt.
Ja, nee, ich war dieses Jahr auch das erste Mal an Tag Minus 1 da.
Der Hype hat sich gelohnt.
Der Späti ist auch nochmal so eine so ein Special.
Punktexte auf Deutsch vorgelesen werden.
musikalisch ein wenig interessiertes nochmal einblick in eine ganz andere szene gewesen.
und was weiß ich nicht alles.
7 Uhr morgens den Zukriegen und was wieso, wo fährst du da hin?
Beschallen lasse, weil es hier die ganze Zeit rumlaufen schon sehr flutend ist an sich.
und bekommen Punkte, wenn sie quasi die KI besser impersonated haben als die KI, überzeugend.
wurden dann genommen und wir dachten wir nehmen dann einfach so eine Community Bühne mit so 100 Leuten ist bestimmt auch super witzig und dann hat das Content-Team bei
uns angerufen, äh angerufen
jetzt gerade hört, macht jetzt Pause und schaut euch an.
Sehr gut.
Was ist die KI-Antwort und was ist die lustigste Antwort?
Und wir haben auch dann multimodale Promes mit drin gehabt mit Bildern.
So ein bisschen auf den Feature Creep eingelassen und nicht nur Fragen an die Teilnehmer, sondern auch noch gleichzeitig Fragen an das Publikum gestellt und die
Publikumsantworten wurden irgendwie gerankt mit, wer hat am schnellsten irgendwie.
einstündige Event ist schon allein faszinierend, allein da zu sitzen und zu sehen, was kann man als Teilnehmer von diesem Spiel oder ein Publikum von diesem Spiel
alles machen und was habt ihr euch einzeln.
irgendeinem Talk sitzen und dann klingelt irgendwie das Telefon.
Du kannst sogar, ich glaube, wenn du einen kleinen Unkostenbeitrag zahlst, stellt die Chaospost auch jenseits von Chaosveranstaltungen.
Tja, Team Gelb hat halt vielleicht Geld.
überhaupt dass die Sachen halt unglaublich schnell alle online sind.
jetzt Core Maintainer von Woodpecker CI ist.
Häufig, was mir auffällt, man geht manchmal am Sendezentrum vorbei und checkt nicht, dass man gerade neben einer Podcast-Aufzeit kommt.
war es schon mitten im Gange, aber die Sendung von heute werde ich mir dann definitiv online nachhören.
Aber ihr hört die Aufnahme sicherlich in wenigen Tagen.
Was ist IRO?
Achso, wir haben 20 Uhr.
Mein persönliches Talk-Highlight aber von den drei, vier Sachen, die ich bisher geschaut hatte, war das vorhin von Arno Semsrod Gegenmacht Best of
Informationsfreiheit.
Ich habe mir, also ich dachte erst, massive FOMO an Tag minus 3 oder so gehabt, dass ich mich gehört habe, das Engelsystem ist komplett überrannt, es bleiben eh keine
Schichten übrig.
Sind wahrscheinlich auch am ehesten wieder weg.
In der iOS-App, wo das so eine schöne Übersicht ist, ganz nach rechts scrollst, hast du angefangen zu scrollen und da hast du gefühlt so drei Minuten lang gescrollt.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und dann kriegen Menschen diese Prompt gestellt und dürfen die beantworten wie eine KI.
Rückblickend, ich hatte ja doler Angst, dass jemand irgendwie, also das war ja für alle Freizfutz zugänglich, also nicht nur vor Ort, sondern halt auch von außen.
Auf der anderen Seite wäre es schon ganz schön assi, dass tatsächlich während so ein Spiel läuft.
Und dann hat das Publikum netterweise auch das mit reingeworfen und mit laut gerufen, dass ab der zweiten Runde auch definitiv mehr Flinters mit auf der Bühne sein
sollten.
Und die KI-Stimme hat immer nur den halben Text vorgelesen.
Der Song aus Monkey Island war halt nicht, also das ist der Song aus Monkey Island, sondern an welcher Szene in Monkey Island ist das die Hintergrund mehr lustig.
adressieren kann.
Oder eine Decknummer draufschreiben, genau, da kann die Leute anrufen.
Also das ist das Thema Telefonieren außerhalb sowieso, aber hier, hier ist Telefonieren ganz fantastisch.
Wochenende.
Und das ist aber keine Zigarettenschachtel an der Stelle, wo ich das rausgenommen habe, sondern es ist eine Fake-Zigarettenschachtel und da drin ist ein Arduino
Nano mit einem Raspberry Pi Chip.
Ihr hört den Congress hinter uns noch live ein bisschen ausklingen.
von vielen und man geht hier so rum und mir ist es auch schon passiert dass ich plötzlich irgendwie neben der aufzeichnung stand und geschnackt habe und dann dachte ich
mir hinterher oh Gott oh Gott oh Gott jetzt habe ich da irgendeinen Podcast reingelabert
Dann ähm Entschuldigung, der Technik.
Ja, ja, ich höre mich jetzt.
Eine Sache, die ich direkt am ersten Tag mitgenommen hatte, ich habe schon häufiger mal von dem Thema Mesh Tastick gehört, mich damit aber noch nie selber
auseinandergesetzt und da gab es beim Hardware Hacking Zentrum unten
inaktiver Workshop, weil du die einzelnen Steps einfach durchgegangen bist und nicht viel selber gebaut hast, aber das war relativ gut die Anatomie von so einer
Gossip-Anwendung in dem, in dem Beispiel durchgegangen.
wo du nochmal höherlewige Anwendungen damit machen kannst.
Das ist ja was, was man bisher nicht so richtig kannte.
Dettantisch zusammengefasst, möchte ich vielleicht erst mal sagen.
Absolut verdient auch.
Hardware Hacking Grundlagenworkshops anzumelden.
Leider so rechts außen, der Begriff gefällt mir dafür nicht.
Und somit ist das Incentive, finde ich, auch ganz schön so da, dass die Leute halt auch lustige Antworten schreiben.
Und es war, also es hat ja eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert.
Genau, und dann könnte Publikum auch noch Prompts abmitten, die sie werden.
Ja, nee.
Aber es ist so.
und 24 gerne dicke CPU.
Das war die erste Iteration, die zweite Iteration auf den Datenspuren war eine neu entwickelte Software, die nächste Iteration auf die Datenspuren war nochmal eine
komplett andere neu entwickelte Software.
und vorher die Batchliste angucken, weil es wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde vorschlagen, wir gehen so ein bisschen unsere Picks und Erlebnisse durch, was wir schon so alles gesehen haben, und dann reden wir über das absolute
Highlight dieser
Also ihr meint, wenn du die Sendeleistung voll hoch schraubst und mir die passenden Einstellung schreibst, dann geht auch sowas wie Shitty Voice.
Wir hatten vorher so ein Kit mit einem Arduino und einer Lichterkette bekommen.
Allein diese complexitation, ich kann an Ticken verstehen that you nach hinten ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten gehabt habt, das ganze Ding so richtig stabil zu
kriegen.
Bei den Leuten auf die Ziffern, die antreffen, auf dem sie warm und um diese Gefahr nicht zu haben, probieren wir es erstmal auf dem ersten.
Also ich meine, wir waren ja schon mehrfach von den Datensprungen gesprochen.
In Dresden.
Genau.
Haben die ein Mesh-Network über Mesh Tastick?
Bin ich offenbar nicht, weil es noch mehr Leute gibt, die noch nerdiger unterwegs sind.
wo der Saal eine halbe Stunde vorher komplett voll war, die Türen wurden geschlossen und dann hieß es einfach, was machen wir jetzt?
Das nächste Buch wird ja auch sicherlich großartig, das nächste Känguru Buffer ist noch groß.
Das Konzept ist, wir geben eine Prompt vor.
Aber manche Sachen sind ein bisschen sehr spontan gewachsen.
Genau, also und dann hast du dir halt noch diese ganzen Security Concerns aufgeladen.
Das war überhaupt kein Thema, aber hätte es Probleme gegeben, hätte ich alle auf.
Wir hatten es getestet mit 6000 Verbindungen.
Wir haben in jeder Runde Gas diese Postkarte, die wir bekommen haben von einer ominösen Person.
Man kann sich mit der Chaos-Post also auch Postkarten zwischen den unterschiedlichen Chaos-Events hin und her schicken.
Kommt auf jeden Fall mal vorbei, falls ihr nicht aus Dresden kommt und das irgendwie einrichten könnt.
Der erste auf meiner Liste, den hast du schon erwähnt, nämlich The Art of Text Rendering und noch diverse andere, die ich hier habe.
Punkte auseinander sein sollen.
Manchmal findet man so Überraschungen, wo man merkt, es ist dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen anders als gedacht, wie zum Beispiel bei dem Markuver Klingtalk, bei
Lesung vor gestern, gestern, wie vorgestern.
Lötworkshop machen und ich habe einfach gesagt, komm, wir melden uns ja jetzt ab.
20 bis 40 oder so von Leuten, die vor den Nazis geflohen sind.
.
Am Anfang habt ihr einen QR-Code für das Publikum eingeschrieben.
Wir hätten by the way auch noch die herrliche Frage gehabt.
Die wollten so ein bisschen über KI in der Lehre und in der Entwicklung der Lehre so ein bisschen was besprechen
Also geht nochmal bei den Postkarten vorbei und hängt die in eure WG.
Folge 62 nächstes Jahr.
Oh Gott, ich war da schon mal in diesem Podcast und habe da das Thema mit dezentralen Codeforges aufgemacht.
Na, äh, müsste er sagen?
Nee, ich höre mich nicht selber.
Ich würde es zum Beispiel ähnlich wie du jetzt gerade bei Mesh Testic beschrieben hast nutzen, um irgendwie so eine kleine Anwendung zu bauen, wo ich permanent Access
auf ein Gerät bei mir zu Hause habe, selbst wenn ich unterwegs bin oder irgendwie so Netzwerke zwischen.
Genau.
Genau, jedes Mal finde ich nach dem Kongress da irgendwelche Sachen, wo ich dachte, hm, da hätte ich eigentlich auch mal hingehen können.
Ich kann das echt verstehen, dass auch du sagst und ich habe auch andere Leute gehört, die sich extra nicht die Talks angucken, sondern lieber alles andere.
Genau, oder da hinten.
Und du hattest gesagt, du hattest noch einen alternativen Server am Start, auf den du hättest umschalten können?
Dann hätte ich einfach alle von euch, da hätte ich euch allen gesagt, geh mal bitte auch 2.
Nee, das ist nichts.
Damals bei der Podcast-Aufzeichnung zu Gitti und Forgio war.
Zu zweit nur, genau.
Nee, nee, Quatsch, das sind ja mit den Mikros ganz gut.
Eine Sache, die ich mitgenommen habe, gleich an Tag 1, das war ganz, ganz spaßig, war mal kurz besonders dabei.
Wir haben den ersten Kanzler gestellt in unserer neu gegründeten Bundesrepublik und wir hatten kurz darauf die Partei, die SRP, die ich die
weil wir halt in Deutschland eine Staatsform haben, die nicht eine Konzepte.
Ich muss mich an solche Sachen langsam rantasten.
Haupttracks, wo Sachen offiziell stattfinden und die sind schon von vornherein da und der Rest, der ganze grün gefärbt.
In Saal, Tag 2 Saal 25 Uhr wart ihr.
GPT-Promps Sekunde.
Ein Vorname, der nicht irgendwo online auffindbar war, aber dann war noch eine Personenbeschreibung dabei und die Personenbeschreibung lautete Hat Bart und trägt
schwarzen Hoodie.
Eigentlich bin ich nicht ganz schlechter Congressbesucher.
Sehr cool.
Also muss ich mich nächstes Jahr wieder bei einem anderen Kurs.
Also es ist ein guter Slot, wenn du halt eh den Stream hitschauen möchtest von irgendwas und dann deine Englische nebenbei bekommen möchtest.
Hollywood Songbuch von, und jetzt habe ich nicht parat, aber das ist auch von Songwritern aus Deutschland, die dann in Hollywood Fuß gefasst haben, nachdem sie vor
die Nazis gefunden sind.
Eine große Gameshow und das ist entweder ist das Hacker Jeopardy gewesen oder wie hieß es letztes Jahr?
Leute, das schneide ich raus.
Und ich kenne das Telefon hat ja sowieso.
Habt ihr Badges gesammelt?
Auf dem Congress.
Dass ich mir extra morgen Vormittag einen Rückzug gebucht habe, weil ich dachte, weil du gesagt hast, du fährst auch um 10.
Okay, steht leider nur darin, dass aktuell 550 Engel arbeiten.
Aber es gibt wirklich, also wir sind ja 16.
Mit dem Telefon.
Man kann da drauf schreiben, was man möchte.
Kann ich dann auch aber heißen, dass wir theoretisch auch schon mal jetzt eine bekommen haben hätten müssen, oder?
Ah, wunderbar, perfekt.
Bei Magnesium hier neben mir, dass du spontan mit eingesprungen und diese Sendung bereitet hast.
Der wird gerade verkabelt und dann kriegen wir ihn potenziell auch gleich noch mit rein.
Genau.
Ja, und und dieses Jahr war es das GPT-Dash.
Benni und ich haben ja auf den Datenspuren die letzten beiden Jahre, also letztes Jahr und dieses Jahr so ein kleines Spielchen gespielt.
Das kann ich auch gut heißen.
Mal schauen.
That's Number Wang.
Also die Infra ist literally unvergleichbar.
So ist gut, so ist gut.
aber halt so festgesetzte Angaben eben in den Buchstaben selbst haben, wie weit jetzt nun die einzelnen Vektoren
Aber das Spannendste fand ich als Takeaway, das kann ich vielleicht sagen, wofür das SRP Plus steht.
Also die Geschichte echolt sich gerade so ein wenig und deswegen fand ich das sehr signifikant, mir das hier mal live vor Ort anzugucken.
Das solltest du nicht spoilern.
.
Ja, oder einfach das interne GSM-Netz nutzen, was genauso geht.
Du bist auch mit drin.
An mich?
Absolut ein Riesendank an das Sendezentrum.
Nee, nee.
Also, das ist auch was, wo ich mich nächstes Jahr nochmal intensiver drum kümmern muss.
Also ich war Tag 0 um 22.
Ben war nicht das erste Mal auf dem Kongress auf der Bühne.
Ich habe gestern Abend eine Postkarte bekommen, da stand er Adressat einfach nur Kailia.
Ah nee, es war kein Name, es war kein Name, es war vor Bühne Y.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche Kleinigkeiten zu erwähnen vom Kongress?
Wie funktioniert das Peer-to-Peer?
Ansonsten gibt es ja die schöne Kongressregel.
Stay subscribed in einer zukünftigen akronymisierbar Folge.
Genau, das war aber zu schön.
Ja, grob leicht.
Aber man kann sich auch Karten an andere Chaos-Events schicken, zum Beispiel an die Datenspuren.
Kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig abstreiten und ich fand es auch interessant.
Also es ist ein ganz fantastischer Talk, muss man sich wirklich anschauen.
Es ging um den Adenauer SRP Plus dieses Mal, quasi zur Komplett Zusammenfassung, was passiert ist seit Inbetriebnahme des Busses.
.
Das war schon ganz cool.
Eigentlich brauchen wir dann keine Wärmung für die Datenspuren zu machen.
Ansonsten gibt es halt noch ein paar Talks, die ich mir auf die Liste geschrieben habe, die ich mir nachher angucken wollte, den über GPG.
Dem OTF-Standard jetzt irgendwie mit drin ist, seit 2016 irgendwie übrigens.
Ich habe mich dann abends im Hotel am Tag minus 1 geschafft für diverse Sachen eintragen zu können.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche Highlights von Sachen, die wir kurz beleuchten wollen?
Und wir haben noch nicht so richtig über Sendezentrum geredet.
Das ist viel besser.
Also die waren damals auch in Leipzig, waren sie das erste Mal da, bin ich nicht alles täuscht.
Da kamen ja so viele Menschen, äh nicht Attack 1, an Tag 0 dann.
Danach bin ich dabei.
Das Spiel war aber eine Web-Anwendung, die man von unterschiedlichen Seiten mit unterschiedlichen Teilnehmern betrifft.
Ne, das sind wir nicht.
Ein Workshop habe ich noch nicht mitgemacht.
Den Namen kriege ich nicht mehr hin, wofür die ZAP stand, aber das war die erste Partei, die im Rechtsaußenspektrum wieder verboten werden musste.
Und heute war ein musikalisches Programm am Nachmittag, nämlich Lieder aus dem Exil, also deutsche Lieder von 20, also von 1920.
Ja, mir tun auch die Leute leid, die das immer haben.
Okay, es war ein Big Blue Button Call.
Also für die Zuhörenden, die das Konzept der Chaos plötzlich kennen, wir haben nicht nur ein eigenes Telefonsystem hier, wir haben nicht nur einen eigenen
SIM-Cardnet, wir haben nicht nur.
Genau.
Wollen wir der Reihe noch rum weitermachen?
Es waren so viele Sachen.
Ich könnte problemlos die Seite laden, ich konnte bloß keine Webseiteverbindung auch machen.
Aber nicht zu lange, sonst werden wir geclaimed.
Ja, genau.
Und da ging es darum, dass jemand erklärt hat, wie das mit den Variable Fonts funktioniert.
Und zwar ging es da konkret um diese Schrift, die in dem CD vom 39C3 jetzt da ist.
Es war schon so viel los, man hat so viele Leute gesehen, so viele bekannte Gesichter, so viel abgehangen mit mit tollen Menschen und einfach eine tolle, schöne Zeit
schon gehabt.
Es gibt auch ganz viele Poster, die überall rumhängen und es gibt deine Telefonnummer für Rust-Notfallfragen.
de macht.
Vielen Dank.
Schön, dass du in der Runde spontan beigetreten bist.
So mit so abgefahrenen Fraktursiven Schriftdaten ist wahrscheinlich dann doch mal schwierig, oder?
Über das Thema wollten wir jetzt sowieso gleich noch ausführlich reden.
Das sind so die ganzen Witze aus dem Orchesterlager, die einem dann anfallen.
Dazu würde ich dich sogar fast noch mal fragen.
Ähm, wir haben auch ein relativ.
Ich hatte auch gerade das Erlebnis, ich dachte, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit vor unserer Aufzeichnung und da gibt es Regines Razzalon.
Ich habe auch gedacht, warum fangen wir nicht einfach an?
Oben kommt's raus.
So, Band läuft offiziell.
Hallo?
Rede ich noch mal ein bisschen lauter?
Und dann gab es noch einen zweiten Workshop, den ich leider verpasst habe, mit nochmal Technologie, die da obendrauf aufsetzt und die heißt P2Panda.
Spannend.
Wie viele Engel gab es dieses Jahr?
Ich habe ihn nicht wirklich verstanden, aber ich habe ihn mir seit 20 Jahren gemerkt.
Der hat immer mal ein bisschen gekraxt.
Ich habe noch eine zweite Instanz der Anwendung gehabt auf einem viel größeren Server, auf den hätten wir umsteigen können, wenn der Server in die Knie gegangen wäre.
Die war von der Knight of Open Knowledge in Lübeck geschickt.
Ich habe es dieses Mal tatsächlich geschafft.
Das gab es, glaube ich, letztes Jahr, wie gesagt, einfach noch nicht.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass ich die Prompts, die alle drin gespeichert waren, auch nicht nehmen konnte.
Ich habe letztes Jahr bei der Pakaos-Post auch mal sehr viel mit zugestellt.
Man kann aber auch so obskure Sachen draufschreiben wie an den Zweitplatzierten der ersten Runde im GPT-Dash.
Nach ihrer erfolgreichen Live-Sendung von den Datenspuren nur die nächste Folge direkt vom Chaos Communication Kongress.
Und ich sehe, wenn ich auf datenspuren.
Für den nächsten Kongress noch mehr LED-Scheiß mitbringen.
Nur müssen wir wieder auf ihre Farbe.
Also chatten ist natürlich so ein bisschen das Offensichtlichste, wenn du halt selber mit dabei bist, dass du halt Nachrichten nennen kannst.
Stimmt, ich habe dich gestern getroffen, wo du eine Palette Pfand durch die Gegend gefahren bist.
Hier vorne, hier vorne, hier vorne, hier vorne.
Also wir haben vom Publikum gehört, dass es tatsächlich halbwegs unterhaltsam war.
Das freut mich sehr, dass ihr das sagt.
Also sagen wir mal so, wir haben.
Die auf der Bühne kriegen jeweils Punkte dafür, aber auch das Publikum kriegt Punkte dafür, wenn die die richtige KI-Antwort erwischen.
Das war so ein bisschen Number Wang, oder?
Ich habe es mir nicht so genau aus.
Nein!
Aber ich höre Ihnen besser.
Genau, die einzelnen Buchstaben, die werden dicker und dünner und länger und breiter und Abstände verändern sich und so weiter.
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur für die.
Das ist einfach nur so eine Vektorgrafik, genau.
Ich habe wirklich versucht, dieses Jahr sehr, sehr wenig Talks zu besuchen bisher.
Also alles ist beliebt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dieses ganze Trivial Feature, was auch sehr cool war fürs Publikum, das war eine Idee vor einer Woche.
Die Musik war ganz fantastisch.
Danke, danke.
Also was, das war auf jeder Fall, also auf den Datenspuren gab es auch, also wir haben jetzt ja keine der Software zweimal benutzt.
Und die Software, die wir nutzen, also beziehungsweise wir hatten eine extra Software, die aber überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Nichts hier.
Also quasi der Kongress nur ein bisschen kleiner mit ein paar hundert, oder vielleicht kann ich vielleicht sogar im vierstelligen Bereich BesucherInnen, bin ich
mir gar nicht sicher.
Es steht hier vorne an der Rolltreppe ein Kippenautomat.
Also das Hintergrundrauschen, da geht man ja selber drin unter.
000 Leute hier und würde mich nicht wundern, wenn etliche davon dieses Jahr mit Engeln.
Vielleicht machen wir es tatsächlich, jetzt wo wir ein paar Learnings hatten, worauf es ankommt, machen wir vielleicht nochmal eine Version dafür und probieren es
nächstes Jahr nochmal und reichen es vielleicht nochmal an.
Ich habe zur Hochzeit gestern mal gesehen, es waren 2000 Leute verbunden.
Aber wie gesagt, da muss man auch ein paar Feinheiten noch, was die Sendeeinstellung mit angeht.
Das wäre dann hoffentlich nicht wieder notwendig, aber das schauen wir in 80 Jahren, wenn es dann wieder so weit ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das sind so die typischen Musikerwitze.
Also es war wirklich sehr chaotisch.
Also ich hab ihr schon in den heutigen Ohrwurmen des Tages die Ohrenhotline angerufen?
Und das findet aber auch ein kleines Kulturprogramm dort statt.
Das ist auch meistens der Tag, der dann wirklich am meisten reinbuttert, weil man meistens erst so um vier wieder hier rauskommt.
Nein, ich hab in den Hub nicht reinschauen.
Sie steht immer noch hinter an.
Wie wird gebraadcastet?
Ah, gut, okay.
.
Wir haben uns die ganze Zeit quasi selber so in den Rücken selber in den Rücken gefallen.
Das hat auch teilweise geklappt.
Danke fürs spontane Anpassen.
Und damit kannst du so Sachen machen wie Dumpipe oder Sendme, diese kleinen Tools, wo man sich Peer-to-Peer-Sachen zuschicken kann, wenn man ein Ticket von jemand
anders hat.
Wir hatten so viel da reingespeichert, wir haben den Fehler gemacht, manche Sachen halt ein bisschen halbherzig.
Wir nehmen hier gerade eine Folge über eine Podcast-Folge auf.
Und dann konnte ich hinterher die Box scannen und konnte mir dafür den Badge Kippenautomat abholen.
Es gibt fünf Leute auf der Bühne, die quasi die Fragen die Prompts beantworten und das Publikum kann dann abstimmen.
Danke auf jeden Fall für die Bestätigung davon.
Was passiert da alles?
Du kannst die auch auf lautlos stellen.
Das war akronymisierbar.
Genau, aber vielleicht bis dieses technische Problem gelöst ist, können wir schon ein bisschen über Sachen reden.
Also schaut euch mal Iro an, der Workshop ist ziemlich cool, der ist noch online auf GitHub und ich verlinke ihn in den Shownotes und dann könnt ihr das mal durchtanzen.
Und wir haben potenziell bis 21 Uhr noch Zeit.
Die machen es ja nicht jährlich.
Aber diesmal weiß ich, mein Takeaway ist, ich weiß jetzt, dass man möglichst in Tag 0 schon dahin geht, auf den Schedule guckt und sich sofort für so einen Workshop
anmeldet und nicht einfach irgendwann geht.
Also ich finde es wirklich ein ganz fantastisches Event bisher.
Das macht Spaß.
Wir hätten noch die herrliche Frage gehabt, was eigentlich eine Bratsche ist.
Es kommt noch wieder eine beiden Datenspringen.
Ich glaube, der hat mit seiner Bratsche auf dem 28C3 schon mal gestanden und hat da ein paar Pausenmelodie gespielt gehabt, was auch ganz fantastisch ist.
Die Hälfte der Show ist ja, also eine Hälfte der Show ist die Show, die ihr macht, aber es ist ja.
Ich habe nicht mal ein Decktelefon.
Oh, danke schön.
Das ist ein AP2040 stand, glaube ich, drauf, oder?
Oder einfach direkt auf media.
Also du kannst dich über das BitTorrent-Netzwerk damit advertisen.
Und das sind dann im Ende verschiedene Einstellungen, die in der gleichen Schrift möglicherweise drin sind.
Das sind diese Sachen, die im Fahrplan dann immer erst irgendwie am ersten Tag auftauchen.
Ich hatte auch den Eindruck, ich habe sehr viele bekannte Gesichter auf der Bühne gesehen.
Warum hast du denn nicht von Anfang angenommen?
Nee, nee, nee, aber die stehen halt an dem Assembly rum.
Aber es gibt natürlich den Sendeplan und die Leute erwarten wahrscheinlich den Stream da zu sehen zu können.
Aber ich bin meistens allein mit dem FOMO, welche Talks besuche ich und so relativ überfordert.
Und ich war schon mit der ersten Antwort, hätte ich schon gedacht, das ist schon ganz schön viel, aber das war noch die kleinste Zahl, die zur Option stand.
gpd.
Nee.
Ich höre ihn auch.
Und da war der Workshop quasi, also eigentlich war es ein relativ
Das ist eh die Überschrift von unserer gesamten Sendung.
Früher habe ich es bisher noch nicht geschafft.
Haben wir das Spiel schon erklärt, wenn die Leute sich jetzt nicht angucken.
Ich habe zumindest hohen Respekt davor, wie viel ihr euch aufgeladen habt.
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schön.
100 bis 500 bis 1000.
30 Uhr hier, bin einmal rumgegangen und dann bin ich so gegen um halb eins erst im Hotel eingecheckt und war sehr happy, dass es überhaupt funktioniert hat.
Ihr habt ja auch noch hier handgemachte Preise organisiert.
Der Publikum konnte Prompt vorschlagen, musste Pro musste Antworten von den Spielern bewerten und musste musste Trivia Fragen beantworten.
Ja, genau, es ist einfach so viel im Hintergrund schiefgelaufen, was hätte ich also quasi Gott sei Dank ist alles kaputt gegangen.
Also sowas gibt es nirgends.
Aber das ist mit äh mit Kolben.
Du musst einfach rumsitzen, um im Evakuierungsfall damit zu helfen, Leute zu evakuieren.
Okay, aber trotzdem.
Ja, wir nehmen einen Podcast auf.
Und dann wird die Frequenz vom Mathe-Mat benutzt, um rauszufinden, wie voll deine Flasche noch
Wir haben ja auch dieses Jahr dort eine Aufnahme gehabt, das ist wahrscheinlich sogar die Folge hier davor.
Beziehungsweise 16.
Es wird besser, es wird besser.
Ich habe allerdings einen Vortrag gesehen, den ich jetzt, wenn ihr mich jetzt direkt danach fragen würdet, als meinen Lieblingsvortrag
Ganz kurz, Meter.
Also ich habe jetzt für mich, uh der my takeaway war es gibt ein
Team Grün!
Oh Gott, das ist FDP da hinter.
Kein Dach, da.
Jetzt sitzen wir hier zu dritt.
Tut mir leid.
Also das ist jetzt das klassische, also aussieht.
Das ist ein bisschen komplexer, habe ich auch selber noch nicht gemacht und kann deswegen noch nicht so viel zu sagen.
Zum Beispiel war uns, was aus den Datensprungen sehr gut ankam, war die Prompt, du bist Christian Lindner.
An dieser Stelle fällt mir ein, dass ich vergessen habe zu sagen, wenn ihr das jetzt noch nicht nachgeguckt habt und diese Folge.
Da hatten wir auch witzige technische Probleme, die habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen auf der Bühne.
Wir haben das im Rahmen von Chaos Macht Schule, haben wir mal an der TU Dresden einen Vortrag gehalten über KI vor Lehramtsstudierenden.
Engel.
Und heute für mich sehr gut, ich habe leider den Namen der Künstler gerade nicht parat, aber ich werde das in den Shownotes nachreichen.
Hat auf den Datenschutz ganz fantastisch mit so 20, 30 Leuten funktioniert.
Ihr braucht es gar nicht nochmal anschauen, die Aufnahme davon.
Der Tonabnehmer hat gar nicht funktioniert.
Da habe ich ja darauf gewartet, dass ihr irgendwann einfach den Ton ausmacht und es einfach von vornherein selbst vorlesen.
Du kannst eine E-SIM oder eine physische SIM-Karte.
Das wird alles live jetzt eingetragen.
Und die Wahrheit ist deutlich komplexer.
Ich will es gut einschätzen können, wo wir viel Zeit uns nehmen.
Ich bin dieses Mal wenigstens in dem Engelsystem angemeldet.
Also bei mir ist es auch schwierig, schon am Tag 0 anzukommen, weil wir meistens noch Familienveranstaltungen am 26.
Allein die Tatsache, dass du dich da hinstellst und eine derartig umfangreiche Anwendung auf dieser Bühne präsentiert hast und ein derartig komplexes Tooling
gebaut hast für dieses
Ich höre's ein bisschen, ja.
Die Postkarten sind wirklich schön.
Aber falls ihr es nicht genau gerafft habt, das ist das Chaos-Event.
Da hast du eine komplette Follow-up-Folge hier noch so in das Ende reingepastet.
Auch nochmal Hausaufgabe für den nächsten Congress.
Er hat gemeint, er hat vieles dazu gesagt, auch in die Richtung auf jeden Fall.
Nice, also den habe ich definitiv auch in meiner Liste der noch zu guckenden Talks.
Und wie du schon meintest, wenn man das halt von außen mit sieht, was so existiert und die Streams oder Aufnahmen schaut, dann sieht man halt die.
Ja.
Was bietet es auch an Möglichkeiten, aber was sind auch so ein bisschen die nicht nur die Shortcomings oder auch die
Wir haben es gerade 20 Uhr Tag 3.
Ja, aber vielleicht nur, weil ich in eure Mikros spreche.
Vielleicht thematisieren wir das in der Zukunft nochmal.
Ansonsten gibt es viele andere tolle Engelschichten.
Aber es war sympathisch, auf die Art und Weise.
Da ging es genauso wenig.
Man kann nicht nur die Streamdumps instant danach schauen.
Tape.
Du kannst es näher an den Mund noch mit rannehmen.
Ging es dabei um Variable Width Fonts oder Variable Character Set Fonts?
Da kannst du ja andersrum machen, sechs Workshops und zwei Talks wäre ja auch für dich.
Ich dachte mir so, naja, wir werden das da wahrscheinlich irgendwie dran löten.
Ich war kurz davor, mich zu melden und zu sagen, ja, ich erkenne das, das ist die Zelda-Melodie.
de gehe, werde ich direkt auf datenspuren.
cc.
Das ist doch fantastisch.
Aber ich könnte mich auch einfach in Dresden hinsetzen und dann versuchen, ein möglichst großes Netzwerk dann aufzuspannen, weil wenn genug Leute zwischendrin
sind, das ist ja das Schöne an Mesh Networking, komme ich damit auch dementsprechend weit.
ZPS ist ja alle zwei, drei Jahre da.
Nächstes Jahr werde ich wahrscheinlich.
Spannend.
Weil der Spieler lebt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon, wenn es möglichst lustig ist.
de.
Te grün!
000 Leute im Hintergrund.
Wenigstens den Anfang davon.
Das war halt der Typ, der zusammen mit
Achso, die habt euch ja direkt angestellt, der Tag 1 bei Mitchell.
Uh, das weiß ich gar nicht, was das Dashboard sagt.
Habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, dass auf dem Späti die aus dem Lufrig geklauten Juwelen stehen?
Und Killian, kannst du ein bisschen was darüber erzählen?
Da stand nichts weiterer Informationen.
Ich habe gerade das freundliche Zeichen bekommen, dass wir so langsam das Ende einleiten sollten.
Den ganzen Technik-Teil, den wir sonst vor der Sendung machen, machen wir jetzt mittendrin.
Mich ganz am Anfang, da muss ich an dieser Stelle Sascha danken, der in dem Zeitpunkt, in dem Moment neben mir stand und gesagt, komm, wir melden uns da jetzt an.
Man kann gar nicht abschirm, wie voll und bunt und die
Das ist meistens dankbarer, wenn sie, wenn sie Mastodon-Handels oder T.
Vielen Dank an das Sendezentrum auf jeden Fall.
regimus-ratzalom.
Weil du es jetzt nicht gesagt hast, sage ich, wo ich mich auch schon drauf gefreut habe, war natürlich der Talk vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Das wäre sehr schön, wenn man das irgendwie vorher hätte organisieren können, dass jetzt jemand hier ankommt.
Und da gibt es entweder hier auf dem Congress schon etliche Notes, also da sieht man gleich, dass das ist.
Ich möchte dazu erwähnen, dass er hier sitzt in einem T-Shirt, auf dem steht Herr Vetica in Comicsans.
Und ich glaube, eine fantastische Zeit hatte ich auf jeden Fall.
Da kamen ja so viele Menschen noch mit an.
Auf der Bühne hat es sich überhaupt nicht so angefühlt.
Wir haben richtig tolle Sachen vorbereitet.
de.
Wie war die 621?
Also Tag 0 war sonst so mein Anreisetag.
Und hat halt gemeint, ja, nee, Community Bühnen sind dies ja nicht, aber wir haben so eine neue Bühne.
Das wirkte so, als ob alles geht außer Websocket.
Also wirklich so, wie wir, also quasi die Storyline, was wir eigentlich machen wollen.
Dementsprechend kommt die nächste akronymisierbar Folge.
Ah, perfekt.
Da gab es noch die richtige Antwort, die ich vergessen habe, aber die, die eigentlich die korrekte Antwort auf die Frage gewesen wäre: All of the above.
Weil ich auf die Idee erst am Tag 0 kam und dann Angst hatte, wenn ich jetzt den DNS-Eintrag von gpt-de umziehe, dann haben wir vielleicht das Problem, dass wir die Hälfte
Das Sendezentrum ist hier überall.
Und dann hat Bart und Schwarzen Hoodie so, okay, mal schauen.
Ich habe auch kein Decktelefon, aber mit Absicht nicht.
Ich meine, das ist ja jedelbe Stream, aber da findet man die Daten alle und das ist ja also nochmal auch ein Riesenlob an ans WOG-Team und alle, die damit involviert
sind, auch als Etralingo und so weiter.
Aber diesmal habe ich zum ersten Mal tatsächlich zwei Workshops mitgemacht.
Wir haben jetzt 20 Uhr sechs und ich habe gehört, wir haben potenziell eine halbe Stunde mehr Zeit als wir.
Und die Geschichten davon und welche davon hinterher in Hollywood als Filmregisseure oder als Filmkomponisten gelandet sind und dann die Songs dazu.
Du bist aber nicht der Einzige, dem so ein bisschen die Demo-Götter geplagt haben.
Aber das ist eine alte Referenz, habe ich dann lange nicht mehr geschaut.
Und wenn ihr aus Dresden kommt, dann seid ihr gefälligst eh schon da und spielt GPT-Dash mit.
Du hast aber glaube ich keinen Ton.
Und dass die dann zu einer Schrift wird, äh.
Man kriegt da Feuerzeuge und Kondome und Masken und Corona-Tests.
Wir sind das Sendezentrum, genau.
Das ist der Chip.
Die Sozialistische Reichspartei.
Nein.
Na, dann machen wir das doch gleich.
.
Ich muss sagen, Team Gelb war richtig penetrant.
Leute behaupten das.
Und dann kannst du eben mit CSS nicht sagen.
Das war das, was du mal kurz gemacht hattest.
Ich hatte ja eh vorher noch das ein oder andere familiäre Constraint über die Feiertage.
Aber wir hatten wie gesagt sehr viele lustige Ideen gehabt.
Das fand ich total wild.
Ohne zu viel zu spoilern, schaut in die Show Not, ich glaube jetzt rein.
Ich habe es nur jetzt extra gesagt, weil wir uns auch fest vorgenommen hatten, Werbung für die Datenspuren zu machen.
Nirgends gibt es was Vergleichbares.
Was ist so die unbeliebteste Engelschicht?
Was?
Da war eine Postkarte, die war adressiert an, da stand glaube ich.
Wenn ihr das jetzt hört und auf dem 42C3 seid, schickt uns doch
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen sicherlich, die Anfang an schon drin sind, aber also die Liste wächst stetig.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Und ich habe mich eine Weile mit ihm unterhalten und ich kann mich nicht mehr so genau daran erinnern, wie meine Produkte
Aber das ist ja auch Teil der Atmo hier, also dass man hier rumgeht und alles irgendwie so ein bisschen mitsieht und mit dabei ist.
Unterschiedlich.
Oder wie advertised du dich?
Dass die Buchstaben an sich jetzt nicht auseinander gehen, während sie dicker und dünner werden.
Das ist ja auch ganz schön, die Sachen im Nachhinein sich anzuschauen.
Und also ich bin einfach so unglaublich glücklich darüber, dass Menschen wie Arne existieren.
Oh, sorry.
Und dann habe ich vergessen, das Chromium-Fenster zu schließen und die TTS-Verbindung spielt aus dem Host-Panel.
Es war sehr nervenaufreiben.
Oder auf Vibration.
Ja, von von wo?
Und den ganzen Backlog der letzten zehn Jahre, denn es war nämlich das zehnjährige Jubiläum von Reginas Rad Salon.
Wir haben noch nicht wirklich angefangen.
Das Konzept ist das, dass diese Geräte miteinander funken, wenn man dieselben Sendereinstellungen hat.
Exakt.
Die hatten ein anderes Gerät irgendwie dran gehangen.
Jetzt gerade in diesem Moment.
Tag 1 oder 2 oder 3 halt die Nachtslots sind immer die.
Auf den Datenspuren lief es so viel besser.
Und bis ich es dann gerafft habe, dass es auch am Sendezentrum eine Podcast-Aufzeichnung ist.
Ja.
Das ist nicht Löten ohne Kolben.
Also gestern gestern waren wir dabei wie ähm
Ich war gestern Abend noch in einer Veranstaltung, die
Und dann ist das wunderschön.
Das hat belebenlos funktioniert.
Ah, da kann ich mir fast vorstellen, wer es war.
Achso, hier.
Ja, komm, wir machen das hier.
Special Feature dieser Sendung ist ein Live Behind the Scenes beim Sendezentrum.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz den Pausescreen von unserer Anwendung gestern, weil der ja auch diese Animation genauso hat.
Und ja, na, es ist halt wie am
Ja, aber das war das war wirklich halb so wild.
Sie schicken auch in die Zukunft und es heißt immer, ab dem 42C3 schicken sie auch in die Vergangenheit.
Hast du mal die Badgeliste geschaut, wie viele 100 Badges es gibt?
Und dann kannst du Animationen.
Hättet ihr komplett restarten müssen.
Wir machen jetzt da drüben weiter.
Also ein bisschen was haben wir schon gesehen.
Ich habe zwölf Stunden geengelt am Tag 0 und war sehr happy damit, dass es einfach ein schöner Tag war.
Das wird vorhin gezeigt, wir haben nur ein paar Plan.
Das Publikum musste aber gleichzeitig auch noch zwischendurch Trivia-Fragen beantworten, während die Teilnehmer auf der Bühne
Sie kam an.
Ich rufe mal kurz die ORM-Hotline hier an.
Das ist ein Konzept.
Zwei Folgen pro Jahr.
Ich habe auch zum allerersten mal einen Workshop mitgemacht und normalerweise bin ich auf
Schaut euch den Talk von Armin Semms aus an.
Das war der dritte erst oder so.
Vor zwei Jahren waren sie das letzte Mal da und jetzt waren sie wieder da.
Ich habe den Angel Welcome Destiny eine lange Zeit lang mit Tag 1 damit umgesessen.
abends war, wo ich gesagt habe, ich kann da nicht kommen.
Eine KI bekommt auch diese Prompt gestellt.
Weil dann hat er die falsche Prompt gespielt.
Ah nee.
Ich meine, es waren irgendwie so 10 Kilometer, aber quasi ein bisschen auf Sicht.
Iro hatten wir tatsächlich schon mal den Picks gehabt.
Also es ist so schön, wie man sich es erwünscht hat.
Es ist wie ein Festival.
Ja, nicht keine generierte Kunst, genau.
Ich habe Teilnehmer bei dem Spiel gesehen, die schon bei den vorherigen Spielen.
Genau, oder welche Farbe hat der Deutschhefte?
Aber man kann sich auch eine Decknummer holen oder eine Telefonnummer intern holen, über einen
Ja, ich weiß, es hängt wahrscheinlich von der Hardware ab, die dann auf die 32C3 verfügbar sein wird.
Genau, also überall, wo die Chaos-Post mit verfügbar ist, kannst du auch, beziehungsweise geht es sogar außerhalb.
Also, ihr könnt aus dem Rauschen eventuell interpolieren, wer hier um uns herum läuft und worüber sich die Leute unterhalten, aber eigentlich wahrscheinlich.
Okay, ich lege meine Hand dafür nicht ins Feuer.
Vorhin kurz angemerkt, die Lesung von Marco Wikling war generell sehr fantastisch.
Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Also da sind ja auch Teilnehmer dabei gewesen.
Und wenn du da halt sitzt und das Telefon klingelt, gehst du halt ran.
Er sagte mir aber, was man so liest.
Wenn ich jetzt weiterrede, achso, vielleicht muss ich es nur dichter dran halten.
Aber man bleibt eher so bei textbasierten Sachen.
Und ja, fand ich spannend.
Du hast versucht, wenig Talks zu versuchen.
Das war dann ein bisschen scary.
Das hatten wir einfach nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Stück Holz und einem Brater?
Heute früh haben wir uns nochmal hingesetzt, haben ein bisschen drüber Quatsch und mittlerweile finden wir es ganz okay.
Ich bin ein bisschen ausgestiegen mittlerweile.
Ich habe noch meine physische SIM-Karte, die habe ich beim Deck den dran gekriegt.
Wir haben jetzt hier bestimmt schon vier Sendungen aufgenommen.
Dein Mikro mit reinkindet.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Aber ich werde mir das tatsächlich.
Also ich muss ja allein sagen, die Komplexität von diesem Spiel hat mich wirklich umgehauen, weil du hattest.
Das war auch kurzzeitig sehr kacke, weil ich halt nichts machen konnte mit der Anwendung.
Aber was die Platine selber rundherum ist.
de.
Das sieht fantastisch aus.
Hier ist nämlich noch mehr aufgetaucht, nämlich der Magnesium spontan.
Wofür steht das SRP Plus?
Wir können mal kurz live nachschauen.
Ich fand es wirklich sehr gelungen.
Wie schaffe ich es denn, diese Low-Orbit-Ion-Cannons von meinem Server wegzuhalten?
Und deswegen sollte man nicht so Larifari, wie ich das vielleicht wahrscheinlich gemacht habe, sagen.
Okay.
Genau, das meine ich ja.
Ja, genau.
Es gab auch einen Glitch, es gab einmal zwischendurch kurz eine Antwort, die
Es ist da kein LAN.
621-Regel.
Es war richtig gut, Clear.
Ich hatte noch eine, also nur für den Fall, dass der Server irgendwie ressourcenmäßig in die Knie geht.
Das ist alles Sendezentrum.
de slash 2026 weitergeleitet.
Und das waren ja nicht mal die Schlangen dann fürs Pändchen.
Wir kriegen vielleicht gerade eine Chaos-Post-Zustellung.
Meistens sind sogar die fertig geschnittenen Sachen dann kurz danach schon online, inklusive Live-Subtitles und Übersetzungen und allem
Da könnt ihr das Tape ordern.
So ist eben so ein Buchstabe definiert.
Ich hätte auch mal einmal eine Schicht damit gemacht gehabt, aber die
Das fand ich ganz großartig.
Dann machen wir doch mal an der Stelle weiter.
Vorsicht, Vorsicht!
Du hast irgendwie diese drei, vier, fünf Haupt.
Wir haben auch so diese Trivia-Fragen fürs Publikum gehabt, damit die
Aber es war sehr schön.
Wir hatten gerade überlegt, ob wir so ein bisschen mal durchgehen, was wir für tolle Sachen bisher erlebt haben auf 39.
Pass auf, es war Löten ohne Kolben.
Jetzt gerade in diesem Moment.
Ihr müsst jetzt Pause drücken, dann macht ihr euch erstmal einen Tum.
Ihr habt das wirklich auch alles gut über die Zeit gerettet, was nicht geklappt hat.
Aber man kann natürlich telefoniere ich nicht so sehr gerne.
Das habe ich tatsächlich letztes Jahr gemacht, da habe ich einfach von hier aus Karten an die Familie geschickt.
Wir snuggeln.
Geht jetzt?
Das geht wahrscheinlich auch nur, kann ich mir vorstellen, mit relativ
Und ich war sehr glücklich darüber, den kompletten Tag 0 hier schon verbringen zu können.
Es ist ja alles so ein bisschen
Das reicht mal auch beim Kongress ein.
Es gibt auch so tolle Sachen, wie wenn du die Nummer Mate anrufst, dann bist du bei Mato Mat.
Danke an Sendet-Zentrum-Team für.
Wir haben auch noch ein paar Themen, die wir vor uns her schieben, um in die Sendung drüber zu bekommen.
Was sind denn so Sachen, die du dir bereits so angeguckt hast?
Ich kann mich beispiel mit meinem Handy oder mit meinem Laptop, mit meiner Note verbinden.
Auf jeden Fall super spannend.
Du kannst aber auch, der Standardmechanismus, den sie letztens eingeführt haben, ist einfach über DNS.
Die Barschicht hat auch super Spaß gemacht.
Aber vielleicht machen wir das in dem Sinne jetzt sofort.
Also jemand anders muss entscheiden, das war jetzt KI und das war Mensch.
Jede WG braucht eine Postkartenbeil.
Ah, wir haben noch einen Gast.
Hast du jetzt den gesamten Talk gespoilert?
Sechs Talks habe ich auch
Es gibt so 50 andere Tracks halt auch noch und das ist keine Untertreibung.
Achso, und eine Sache, die auch noch passiert ist.
Und dann hatten wir spontan einfach gesagt, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Da kommst du beim Rust-Assembly raus.
Da ein bisschen mehr drüber zu erzählen.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein ganz fantastischer Konquest.
Also so wie so ein Buchstabe aussieht, wenn man einfach mal einen Buchstaben nimmt.
Aber es ist keine sehr aufregende Englische.
Und halt meinte auch, dass die komplett vernetzt sind, also bis nach San Francisco hoch.
Es hat natürlich einiges gehakt.
Wir sind noch nicht ganz durch, aber wir stehen noch nicht mehr am Anfang vom Event.
Das hast du ja schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
So grob.
621, das ist nämlich 6 Talks.
Bis es mir dann zum Schluss auffällt.
Und das ist was, was der Späthi als Programmpunkt.
Aber ähm
Das ist wohl irgendwann zu halber Zeit irgendwie abgefallen und haben dann dran geduckt.
Und der Server hat jetzt irgendwie 250 Gigabyte RAM.
Nee, ich hab.
Nee.
Akronymisierbar Folge 62 vom 39C3 und die nächste.
Dieses Mal.
Wo war ich?
Die Antwortmöglichkeiten wären gewesen, eine Bratsche ist eine Geige für die Leute, die sich keine Geige leisten können.
Ich hätte heulen können.
Wollen wir ein bisschen über den Kongress reden?
Der hat sich glaube ich, da gab es irgendeinen Scheduling-Konflikt, deswegen konnte ich da nicht mit drin sitzen.
Aber im Normalfall kann man ja alles dann in der Aufnahme mitnehmen.
Gerade bei dem Talk sollten wir vielleicht nicht zu viel vorwegnehmen.
Das war sehr scary, wie gesagt, uns darauf vorzubereiten.
Ich will nicht, dass jemand das Ding in die Knie trenkt, die so.
Kann man 5 Euro reinstecken und dann kriegt man eine Zigarettenschachtel raus.
Nee.
Und dann kam er einfach auf die Bühne und hat schon mal vorher schon mal jenseits der Auf.
Man kann auch nicht alles besuchen.
Das hat mir Benni und Ben dann erzählt im Nachhinein.
Du hast wahrscheinlich nur relativ kleine Payloads damit verstehen.
Und dann hinterher war dann so das Feedback, dass es hieß, ich dachte, du bist ein Schriftmerk.
Allgemein, der fährt für mich in diese Kategorie der Serien-Talks.
Es ist ein Festival.
Wollen wir nicht sowas noch machen?
Ich fax in die Shownotes.
Auf der Welt.
Und dann habt ihr euch aber erst
Weil ähnlich.
Von wann?
Team Gelb hat Teamlogos.
Also ich höre mich immer noch nicht selber.
Aber der Sinn ist, du hast halt so eine Vektorgrafik und das ist ein Buchstabe.
Und die muss ich auch spontan nur wieder reinladen.
Es liegt LAN, da ja, aber das habe ich bilderweise nicht genutzt, da hätte ich drauf kommen können.
Und dann bin ich da rumgelaufen.
Schönerweise kann man sich in der Fahrplan-App auf dem Telefon hier die Sachen sternen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Hast du heute früh einen Corona-Test gemacht?
Sie können tatsächlich dabei auf mehrere Mechanismen zugreifen, nicht nur zum Beispiel die
Also dieses Jahr die große Gameshow an Tag 1
Du hättest ja genauso gut einen einstündigen Vortrag über die Implementierung von dem Spiel erhalten können.
Da gehen übrigens Props ein.
Ich finde es cool, mich damit auseinandergesetzt zu haben.
Also das Plus steht für, es wurde bereits eine rechte Partei verboten.
Und am Ende dürfen Leute abstimmen darüber, was war denn die echte KI-Antwort.
Und nicht alle nur so hölzerne Antworten schreiben, die halt nach KI klingen.
Aber die Chaos-Post ist ein tolles System.
Ja, wie cool.
Mach das nicht, das ist ein Shared Medium, was die herwegst.
Und der erste war ein Aero-Workshop.
Die, ähm, also der Konrad Adenauer hat damals ja als auch Verfolgter des Nationalsozialismus
Das ist übrigens, was ich nochmal erwähnen möchte an dieser Stelle, ist vielleicht, wenn, wenn man den Congress nur aus der Ferne beobachtet und sich die Streams
anguckt.
Also, ich habe gestern einen Schunk vorher getrunken.
Also die Anwendung hatte irgendwie mit 100 MB RAM da einfach so Gewerke.
Mal schauen, was heute da ist.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Weil es einfach saufile sind, diese Access-Control-Schichten, aber das ist einfach, weil es
Schau mal, da sind wir im Sendezentrum und so.
Also
Und das war jetzt auch nochmal neu.
Genau, Iro hatten wir schon mal den Picks und das ist ein Set von Protokollen oder Libraries.
Die erlaubt, dass sowas eigentlich existieren darf.
Herrlich.
Ich habe mir nicht so viel gemerkt, bis auf die Tatsache, dass.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu viel versprechen.
Aber wenn das nicht eintritt.
01 oder 2.
Zum Beispiel, dass auf der ersten Runde ausschließlich Männer auf der Bühne saßen.
Und das fand ich großartig, dass die mich gestern erreicht hatte.
Da gab es Leute, die haben daneben gelungert.
Den habe ich auf meiner Liste und habe den leider nicht geschafft.
Killian, hast du noch irgendein Highlight vom Progress?
Ich muss
So wie das beim Conquest passiert.
Die kleinste Bühne sind so 400 Leute, wird das für euch auch passen.
Da habe ich dann auch mit versucht, darauf zu achten.
Aber wenn du das richtige Studio meinst, das ist ganz hinten und dann in die Tür rechts rein.
Weil als ich dann nämlich am nächsten Tag, als das stattfinden sollte, da stand und die
Aber letztendlich
Bockschichten um Bottle Operations hat da finde ich, machen auch mega immer Spaß.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Ach stimmt, genau.
Vielleicht hätte ich da gestern Abend nochmal anrufen sollten.
Also es funktioniert über LoRa, also es ist alles LoRa under the hood.
Das ist im Shift-Dashboard, Public Dashboard.
Es war ein bisschen Chaos, weil absolut nichts.
Heute gab es auch ein, zwei Vorträge auf
Nicht GPT, sondern GPG.
Mir ist gerade noch was eingefallen, was ich.
Es ist absolut ein Festival.
GPT-Dash, genau.
Ich muss das jetzt on the air sagen.
Ja, okay, das klingt eigentlich ganz fastig.
Böderweise hat das aber auch die ganzen Trivia-Fragen, die wir eingetragen haben, rausgelöscht.
Aber wie gesagt, also gestern Abend waren wir beide dann so ein bisschen verzweifelt.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist es so, dass es eine API gibt, die in
Was soll ich denn machen an Tag 0?
Und dann Tag 1 konnte man dann wirklich so entspannt starten in den tollen Kongress und das das
Und das weiß ich, weil ich zufällig.
Ach, guck's dir an.
Also generell Status-Messages, Geräte, die irgendwie Daten irgendwie zurückschicken müssen.
Nee, nee.
Und das haben wir eigentlich gar nicht, also wir haben sich answeise rüberbringen können, was wir eigentlich vorhatten, weil halt wie gesagt die technischen
Probleme dann so ein bisschen dazwischen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber das war entweder das halt geklappt oder das war gar nicht das Problem.
Hallo?
Team Gelb macht aktiv Werbung online auf Master.
Live?
Was bedeutet die Wirtschaft für dich?
Dezember haben und da kann ich dann meistens am Tag 0 erst
Also quasi 1, 2 oder 3, bloß halt mit 0,1 oder 2.
Auf dem Datensprung war das dieselben Leute, da haben alle SpielerInnen quasi selbst mit abgestimmt.
Oh, die Türvia-Frage, weil wir haben es alle verkackt, vorher zu wissen.
Wir hatten noch den Ben mit dabei, der Bratsche gespielt hat.
In dem Sinne haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, genug Werbung für den Congress gemacht.
Also in dem Sinne bedanke ich mich auch.
Die größte allergrößte Katastrophe ist das Kommunikation
Und ich dachte, ich dachte, komm, ich muss endlich mal so einen Löt
Obwohl ich auch manchmal gerne zur Entspannung dann wirklich doch einfach in irgendein Talke und mich ein bisschen be
Ja, das passiert auf dem Kongress.
Und dann war die Frage aber eigentlich nicht, ist das die Zelda-Melodie, sondern.
Von vorher.
Also wenn ihr natürlich unseren Feed kennt.
Also die Vorbereitungen laufen bereits.
Ich find's ein bisschen geil, muss ich sagen.
Also ihr habt es schon bei zwei Datenspuren gehabt.
Aber genauso fantastisch von Freitag bis Sonntag, meist so im Herbst, September, Oktober rum irgendwie.
Hier ist eine Mesh-Stic-Node.
Und das ist ja auch ganz wunderbar, dass das ganz schnell auf mediacc.
Es sei denn, wie gesagt, im Worst Case passiert was, dann hast du natürlich eine Verantwortung.
G
Geil.
Also die ist sowieso zu empfehlen, sich die nochmal anzuschauen im Nachhinein.
Wir haben ja habt ihr bei den Datenspuren auch
Das hat sich auch ständig immer mal die Mechanik immer so ein bisschen geändert.
Die
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich hinkriegen.
Es ist ein absolutes Festival.
Und zwar gab es bei den beim Kongress jedes Jahr.
Frag mal bitte den Techniker da drüben.
Ich liebe generell alles an Infra, was hier aufgezogen wird.
Ja?
Auf jeden Fall.
D
Also, wir haben nämlich ein relativ schnackes Programm, bevor hier die nächsten Leute auftauchen.
Gab es das in der dritten Runde da?
Und ich habe jetzt zum passende Hardware dafür und werde mich damit auch weiter auseinandersetzen.
.
Nee, gestreamt wird er nicht dieses Jahr, meinst du?
Also aller allerdringlichste Nachguck-Empfehlung, falls ihr den noch nicht gesehen habt, schaut euch den an.
Nächstes Jahr möchte ich versuchen, auch mal eine Englische zu machen.
Und im Rückblicken war das ja.
Es lief etwas, wir hatten Spaß dabei und ich bin auch sehr dankbar, dass das vieles funktioniert hat.
Keine Ahnung wann das war, auf welchem Kongress.
Es gibt ja so viel Exploration-Scheiße, es gibt ja so viel Kram, was du einfach entdecken musst.
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, wie die Wurst gemacht wird.
Also es war einfach nur.
Endlich früher fürs Engeln anmelden.
Wir hatten schon Angst, dass wir zu zweit hier sitzen.
Das ist die einzige Badge, die ich gesammelt habe.
Also man kann diese sich ja so vorkonfigurieren, dass nicht alle Schriftzeichen drin vorkommen, wenn man das optimieren will.
Das ist meine ganze Absicht, dass ich den gesamten Tag durchengeln kann.
Ich verbringe meine Kongresse tatsächlich fast ausschließlich in den Vortragsseelen.
Ich war auseinander, ich glaube, der Mikro passt schon.
Genau, genau, genau.
Wir gehen jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen Reihe um und dann würde ich einen Themenwechsel irgendwann machen.
Ist bestimmt die nächste Folge.
Also die Lesung war von Anskaja.
Die Publikumsteilnehmer, die am schnellsten
Ich bin auch schon mal rangegangen.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein Highlight.
Natürlich.
So wie ich schließe.
Mal schauen, ob das dieses Jahr nochmal passiert.
Da werde ich nachher nochmal dran vorbeigehen.
Genau.
Nein, gespoilert würde ich nicht sagen.
Das Plus steht für wir müssen das wieder tun, genau.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt durch den Workshop und durch den Kippenautomaten
3.
Wenn das nicht eintritt, machst du gar nichts.
So war das nicht gemeint.
Ah, okay.
Wo es einfach auch jedes, das einfach
Gott sei Dank habe ich das gar nicht mitbekommen gehabt.
Man kann Chaospost Postkarten verschicken.
Wir haben 20 Uhr sechs, habe ich gesagt.
Das war einfach so ein
Die CPU hat quasi geheide zwischendrin.
Sehen wir jetzt hier auch direkt auf.
Ich musste mich auch entschuldigen.
Also man hat es natürlich schon mitbekommen, ihr habt das ja auch immer gesagt, aber.
Zwei Datenspuren, einmal dieses Jahr und einmal für letztes Jahr, genau.
Die Barschichten machen auch mega Spaß.
Nice.
Und das ist ja was, was man.
Also ein Ticket ist eine irgendeine Adress-Identifier.
War erhellend.
de alles ist.
Das Problem war, dass wir halt so Probleme hatten.
Echt?
Schön, dass du dabei bist.
Also ich werde auch die Slides mal verlinken, da wird schön erklärt.
Genau.
Ja, ja, jetzt.
Die haben eine Kampagne.
Wir sind danach noch ein Zoom trinken gegangen.
Aber es macht sich erreichbar, wenn man dir eine Karte schickt.
Hi Kirjan, hi Hendrik.
Die habe ich jetzt dabei.
Plötzlich hat man
Ja?
Wir haben 20 Uhr.
Und das wäre ein bisschen lame.
Weil der Späti ist zwar
Oder?
Aber das müssen wir aus Brandschutz.
Ja, freut mich auf.
Und das ist für mich als jemand, der.
24, 25.
Holy shit.